JONATHAN VINOCOUR: ECCO, is
a conductor-less string
orchestra that's about--
we usually play
with about 18 people.
So a bunch of us started it
back when we were just in
school, or just out of school,
and looking to play pretty
much just for fun with a bunch
of our friends in a small
conductor-less orchestra.
Most of us were playing a lot
of chamber music and just
thought it would be
fun to read some
actual orchestra music.
When we just out listening,
it sounded so great.
KATE DREYFUSS: It was inspiring
to see Jonathan come
back to Princeton, as someone
who followed the same
academic, or similar academic
paths as many of the students,
and yet went on to become
a professional musician.
JONATHAN VINOCOUR: I just
remember always looking
forward to coming to orchestra
rehearsals, because in
orchestra it always felt like
I could just relax and enjoy
the music making.
And especially doing it with
all these other people, and
knowing that there were all
these other people on campus
who wanted to be doing
the same thing.
NATHAN HALEY: There's
performances just happening
all the time.
Princeton, I think in all areas,
but especially in the
music department, is just
bursting at the seams with
opportunities.
And it's a great place to get
involved in all sorts of extra
curricular activities.
KATE DREYFUSS: What was running
through my mind was, I
just could not believe that I
would sharing the stage with
such accomplished musicians
who are involved with
ensembles all across
the country.
And as I was watching them,
during the first half, I was
in awe of their energy.
And I felt that energy
the moment that
I stepped on stage.
NATHAN HALEY: Performing with
ECCO was absolutely amazing.
Their energy and their
focus is infectious.
And just everyone on
the stage felt it.
This warm and vibrant direction
towards the
performance.
And it was amazing to see
everyone just light up and
focus, and turn to the music.
And it really came
alive for me.
[ORCHESTRA MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]